[Musique]
la disparition de john franklin et ses
nombreux marins dans l'arctique canadien
au 19e siècle demeure un mystère
contrairement à une hypothèse répandue
une nouvelle recherche conclut que les
équipages des deux navires de
l'expédition ne serait pas mort d'une
intoxication au plomb ils sont partis en
héros en 1845
l'explorateur john franklin et 128
membres de la marine britannique kate
l'angleterre à la recherche du passage
du nord-ouest
ils veulent être les premiers à passer
de l'atlantique au pacifique en
naviguant au nord du canada
on ne les a jamais revus depuis plus de
cent soixante dix ans on tente de
comprendre ce qui avait pu se passer
db cooper biologiste à l'université de
saskatchewan viennent résoudre une
partie de l'énigme
il a analysé les ossements de 11 marins
retrouver dans l'arctique canadien
[Musique]
je ne suis pas un spécialiste de
l'histoire navale
mais cette aventure m'a fasciné c'est un
événement fondateur de l'histoire du
canada john franklin et ses hommes ont
voyagé à bord de deux navires le terror
deliry bus ils passent leur premier
hiver dans l'arctique canadien
près de lille bitchy trois membres de
l'équipage moeurs et sont enterrés au
printemps l'expédition reprend sa route
mais pas pour longtemps
les navires vont rester pris dans les
classes près de l'île du roi guillaume
en 1848 et survivant abandonne les
navires tentent de fuir à pied
les ossements humains ont été retrouvés
à différents endroits le long de la côte
nous avons des ossements de lille dit
shi et d'autres appartenant à des marins
morts plus tard sur l'île du roi
guillaume
[Musique]
dans son laboratoire d'éveil cooper
découpe des fragments d'os
il veut mesurer la concentration de
plomb qui se trouve à l'intérieur
nous avons des fémurs des tibias et des
eaux provenant de bras car ce sont ceux
qui se conservent le mieux selon une
hypothèse répandue les membres de
l'expédition ont été décimés par une
intoxication au plomb
la forte concentration de ce métal ont
été retrouvés dans les ossements les
cheveux et les tissus de certains marins
lord analyses réalisées dans les années
1980 les boîtes de conserve que
transportait le navire avait été scellé
avec du plomb on en trouvait aussi dans
les canalisations d'eau potable
c'était un métal couramment utilisés à
l'époque des vies de couple va pousser
les analyses plus loin il va utiliser un
appareil hors du commun qu'on appelle un
synchrotron une espèce de micro scope
géant
il pourra non seulement voir s'il ya du
plomb dans les os mais déterminer à quel
moment les marais ont été contaminés le
synchrotron nous permet de voir
exactement où se trouve le plomb dans
les structures osseuses comme les eaux
se transforme au fil du temps on peut
estimer si les marins ont été exposés
pendant une brève ou longue période dans
les tuyaux du synchrotron des électrons
voyage à une vitesse qui frôle celle de
la lumière des aimants les font tourner
plus changer de direction
ils émettent alors des rayons x très
intense qu'on envoie vers les
échantillons d'os le plomb absorbe cette
énergie et émet des radiations
c'est ainsi qu'on arrive à le repérer
dans les eaux il ya des cellules qui
élimine les vieux tissus osseux en
creusant des trous et d'autres qui
remplissent
le biologiste veut vérifier c'est la
concentration de plomb plus élevé dans
les tissus osseux qui se sont formés
durant l'expédition en regardant les
structures qui étaient en train de se
former au moment de la mort on constate
que la concentration de plomb n'est pas
particulièrement élevé
en fait il y au point que l'on sait sur
ceux qui se sont formés plusieurs années
avant l'expédition et dont les tissus
osseux récents cela indique que les
marins n'ont pas souffert d'une
intoxication aiguë durant le voyage
ils ont plutôt été exposés à de petites
doses de plomb tout au long de leur vie
ce qui n'est pas normal pour l'époque
les chercheurs ont tiré les mêmes
conclusions
en analysant 2 dans on voit ici de dents
trouvées sur l'île du roi guillaume il
ya beaucoup de plomb dans la couche
externe qui s'est formé durant les
dernières années de vie mais il y en a
autant dans les couches sous jacente ce
qui indique que ces marais ont été
exposés au plomb bien avant le début de
l'expédition pour régler la question une
fois pour toute l'équipe de david cooper
a comparé les ossements trouvés dans
l'arctique avec ceux d'autres membres de
la marine britannique ayant vécu à la
même époque dans les deux groupes
les concentrations plomb était similaire
[Musique]
tous ces indices nous mène à conclure
que l'équipage de franklin n'a pas
souffert d'une intoxication aiguë les
durant le voyage
la question demeure comment ces hommes
sont ils morts
c'était une situation désespérée la
nourriture commençait à manquer on a
retrouvé des indices de cannibalisme sur
les ossements l'arctique et un
environnement extrêmement rude et les
marins ou probablement souffert de
toutes sortes de problèmes de santé
le voile se lève peu à peu sur cette
expédition mythique mais elle conservera
toujours une part de mystère
[Musique]